Jocko. I have a question for
you. I know you're very busy guy.
How do you find time to
read so many books? I have.
I have many that I want to read,
but I've trouble having enough time.
Any advice on how to set
aside time to do so? Uh, sure.
All right. Lay It on me.
Make time. What are you,
what are you doing all day
the taken?
What are you doing all day? Are you
watching TV? Are you surfing the Internet?
Are you watching youtube videos?
That's my question.
What are you doing before you go to sleep
at night? Are you looking at Twitter?
Are you looking at Instagram posts?
The Instagram videos.
Tell me they're not the like an
addiction. Yeah, you get the,
you get the Instagram video. Every one of
them is funny. They're 38 seconds long.
The one minute long.
Get to see people hurt themselves.
Get to see people do dumb things and
make you feel good about yourself.
I didn't do that dumb thing and
someone else did. I can laugh at them.
How long are you going to look at those
videos for? When you could be reading. So,
so there you go. Stop wasting a bunch of
time. And then what about audio books?
What are you doing when
you're mowing the lawn?
you're trimming the hedges?
What are you doing when
you're pulling weeds?
What are you doing when you're cleaning
the dishes? Get some audio books.
Get some audio books. What are you
doing first thing in the morning?
What are you doing?
Are you waking up,
checking your email,
sitting around waiting, you
know, wasting a bunch of time.
Are you getting up early enough that
you could just get up, get out of bed,
go and read for 30 minutes,
30 minutes? That's what you have
to do. You have to make time.
There's plenty of time to read.
You probably don't want
to read as badly as your,
as you think. If you wanted to
read that bad, you'd make time.
You make time to breathe somehow.
You can make time to breathe.
You can make time to read. Yeah, I
wouldn't say it's the best. Yeah,
he would be a better one because
like, yeah, eat I think because read,
you can read while you're doing other
things sometimes, especially with just,
just kind of like as a,
as a, uh, so I'm reading,
I'm always have to be reading a book to
read a book for the broadcast, right?
Yeah. I had only read the first maybe
10 books that we read that we did on the
podcast. We've done a hundred or
something now. Probably more than that.
I'd only read like 10 of them
and maybe it, maybe a few more,
but I'd read them so long ago.
Maybe I'd read 30,
but some of them so long ago that just,
I had to reread them.
And so then you say to yourself,
okay,
so when would you know when I read all
the time or we'd go to bed greeting,
wake up reading, um, uh,
going in an airplane,
see people, what do people
do in an airplane? You Watch
a movie, I know you sleep,
they do all this stuff.
I sleep sometimes in an airplane,
but we're from not sleeping, get
us. Guess what I'm doing? Reading,
prepping for a podcast
and I can attest to, yeah.
Uh, what do you think is the,
like the biggest ones that people
are, um, you know, that, you know, the,
the biggest activities they could,
yeah.
They could just stop and it just, uh,
for me, I think the biggest time sucks.
Our Youtube.
I think Instagram.
Yeah.
I think those two are really, um, what's
the word? Stimulating to the brain.
And you actually get this weird
like, well, I actually like,
I'm going to learn a little
something from this right here.
I'm gonna take something away from this.
I'm going to veg out.
I'm going to escape
from my world right now.
It's like escapism, right?
Yeah. And, and they look,
they actually have
algorithms that are stat,
know what you will click on.
They actually know that about you.
They mapped your little brain and know
that if they put up a video that has,
if they put up a thumbnail of a video
and it's got a heavy machine gun in it,
they, they know they got a good chance.
I'm going to click on it. Right.
And then they give it a catchphrase title,
right? Nope. They give it a catchphrase.
Title. Isis gets massacre.
I gotta watch that.
Yup.
I'll click 50 cal vs Taliban.
Oh, cool. Click right?
Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah.
And actually know words you're going
to click on. And that's, that's so,
and what do you get out of it?
You Watch it for 20 minutes.
Short game. Yeah. You get nothing out of
it. You get a book, you read, you learn,
you'll write something.
That's what you do.
Yeah. That, and actually
the youtube thing is,
it's funny if that's one of your things,
it's worse than,
it's not just youtube who's trying
to get you to watch the video.
It's the video makers themselves.
So you do has the Algorithm, oh,
they got it all kind of sorted out there.
And now the video makers,
they make titles like 50 cal versus
Xyz and the awful punching those too.
And guess what?
50 cal versus you can fill in the blank.
You're probably going to watch that video.
It doesn't have that motivation
speech ever. Yes. Oh yeah.
So,
so in,
so destroys whatever destroys
reporter in interview.
Exactly right.
So once you really own,
cause those are the actual things are
actual, so basically doubled, right?
When you log on to youtube, once
Youtube pops up on your screen, Bro,
everyone on that screen is all
sucking your attention. Literally.
That's their job. Sucking your attention.
So yeah man, that's a big one, right?
Instagram. So here's the, here's the,
here's the one that it really hit me
really hard that Graham and I like
Instagram. It's like good. But if
you're like trying to read, you know,
if you want to read more or whatever,
consider like even like let's say we
start recording just for a second,
we're going to look on the bus,
on our phones.
We're gonna maybe checking email
and maybe we got a text or whatever.
And the Cha, the probability of
Instagram coming up on there,
we're going to open it. But the
probability of US opening Instagram is,
it's pretty significant. It's pretty
high. And you can scroll through there,
whatever. Even if you school
for two, three minutes, right?
You scrolled through there. Maybe you
what? You looked at a, I don't know,
1520 people's posts.
Read what they had to say.
If you have a, what do you, what do
you call like kindle or something,
but you do that same thing.
It's like can the end,
like you're saying you can read. Yeah.
Read instead. So if you had a camera,
like once you said like imagine
you're giddy being videotaped.
Like what if you're being videotaped all
day and all he did was calculate every
time you opened up Instagram or
Facebook or Twitter and or youtube,
all those Ptr,
every time you open up at,
and he had that scenario
in one average day.
Then you take all that time
and replace it with, you,
opened your kindle to read more,
busts out a book. You know,
you've bringing books or whatever we do.
And that's how to, instead of doing that,
you did the book, Brian, you know
how much reading you do, right?
You'd read so much. Yeah. So it's like
the, yeah, those are the time sucks man.
Your phone, it's so available, you know?
But probably you can read on your
phone too. That's a big one. TV Too.
He Watch TV. Not really.
I watch one show now.
It actually to Hawaii, five o and that's
it. Sometimes Shark tank. That's it man.
100%. It's weird. What does it,
how often does the Hawaii five o on
once a week and it goes in seasons.
So you got, how long has this season?
I Dunno. 13 episodes I guess. I Dunno,
I have no, no, no, but on the last,
I have watched one TV show recently.
It's called billions.
Oh Wow.
Little scenario unfolding on billions.
All right,
well you can actually actually,
there you go. Yeah. And keep in mind,
it's not like I've never seen any
other show ever. It never will.
It's not that they're just saying,
you know how people they like made
watch Tino routinely and actually, um,
I will separate the fact that nowadays
you can watch TV in a different way.
Right? It's not like at eight
o'clock on a Thursday night.
You've got to sit there and watch it.
30 minutes show with the 30
minutes worth of commercials in it.
Yeah. Right. No, you can. You're, you're
on a flight somewhere.
You've read,
you've got to take it easy
on your eyes a little bit.
If you start reading too much,
you've read for a long time. Okay.
You're going to stare out the
window for a little while,
listen to this part of a podcast or
something. Then you're like, okay,
my brain is like barely functioning.
Okay.
I'm going to watch an episode of billions.
Yeah. On you ever seen ballers?
I Dunno, the different, well,
I do know the difference.
I watched that for a little bit,
but you know like people have a
routine like tonight, you know,
every night for 30 minutes they
watched TV with their kids or whatever.
It's like that doesn't
really happen anymore. Yeah.
Next question. Really Sad.
How much time you can waste these days
with the distractions that are people
trying to get that time from you.
Yeah. Your discipline. Like when you,
when you first started saying
disciplining quick. Oh,
when I first started hearing it from you,
that was like one of the things
that popped into my head.
Like as being really obvious, like if
you are disciplined with your time,
you'll have a lot of free time.
Like a lot, a lot of free time,
way more than you would think anyway.
Because you know,
even when I'm like real busy, you know,
if I can accurately remember my day,
I can remember like just like five
minutes here, 15 minutes there like that.
I did something that was a waste of time.
And if you add up all those little
minutes you have probably hours proffer,
showers for to do,
do something for progressive,
you know, productive,
progressive, progress, your
life, valuable, valuable,
all those things in check.